how's go imprisonment today we are going
to families it's been a while I missed
it as you know there's been a lot of
drama lately about celebrity news being
leaked on the internet so I thought we
would dedicate this video to that Oh
Jennifer Lawrence
we started liking you and then we
realized you're just annoying now
probably getting a gonna get a lot of
[ __ ] for this apparently everyone loves
her but that doesn't mean we can't have
fun
god damn it I don't want to look at this
work of art let's see how many people
get offended you need help
Thanks steady classy nice topic rice oh
my god yeah that was probably not
appropriate but she doesn't even have a
Twitter so cares why isn't this at a
museum I don't know probably cuz it just
was made a second ago literally next one
oh yeah we never did do Beyonce did we
all right Beyonce your time has come so
beautiful such an inspirational woman
what could we possibly do to change her
I know what happened there that's some
freaky [ __ ] man
embrace your flaws Beyonce that's what I
always admired you for I did her I brag
oh there it is
hey eyebrow Oh eyebrow that is so
typical you you thought I was an eyebrow
no I'm a snake no wait that's not it if
you like event shade burn a ring on it I
feel like it should better eat honey
that's a song right beyoncé became demon
Jesus I don't know how this
transformation
haha thank you
not all the comments I always knew it
nice Maseca and yet he likes it too your
brother max of me - Fabul eyes myself
son begin the beginning and I I feel
like it's time so alright let's just do
this one let's just work with a liquid
fire that's pretty good
hahahahahaha what what is happening haha
alright let's just I'm sorry all right
let's see here and then we what the [ __ ]
what is this shake Iggy Azalea however
you say it
everyone suggested it Oh huh hallo hallo
she got buns Oh God kill it
my anaconda don't my anaconda don't
beautiful this beautiful this is
alright you can't criticize it alright
let's give it a way prettier face so
gout getting there we're getting there
it's actually pretty damn attractive
there we go fabulous let's take a look
from the beginning not fabulous damn
family's got a little I always real of
rating your breast reactions alright we
need one more to finish this [ __ ] I
think we should do a boy yeah I'm not
gonna bother doing that alright we can
work with this dit dit dit dit dit dit
dit dit dit dit dit
that they take today today today today
today today
all right Alex pray to get everything I
think it needs more passion and more
balance uh actually looks pretty good
ha ha ha ha ha oh my god that's
hilarious
ha ha did the ice all right Chris got on
that episode there I hope you enjoyed
watching please go ahead and leave a
like if you did
helps me out a lot there you go and
here's some broken for you as always
stay awesome rose